okay we have a David Pakman show
subreddit which is one of the bigger sub
reddits of progressive independent shows
now more than ten thousand three hundred
fifty david pakman show viewers and
listeners who are subscribed to the
david pakman show subreddit I told a
story on the Tuesday bonus show my first
day back from my trip which included a
visit to France and a visit to Italy I
told the story of using my Spanish
fluency to try to communicate with a an
Italian taxi driver and this story is
like nothing that we've had in probably
years on the David Pakman show bonus
show in terms of the reaction that it is
triggered from so many people in our
audience and a very very funny meme was
posted to the subreddit which says it's
a guy pouring coke into a Pepsi can with
the headline trying to modify my Spanish
vocabulary to speak Italian hoping no
one will notice well listen people
noticed when I used the word fika which
means fixed which of course is not a
sound that J sound is not a sound that
even exists in Italian to try to discuss
with the taxi driver whether it was a
fixed price trip or not he noticed it
was not fooling anybody but check out
the Tuesday bonus show sign up on our
website check out that story and let me
know what you think people titillated
disgraced ashamed and horrified by that
story from the Tuesday bonus show also
from the David Pakman show subreddit a
baseball team I didn't get to cover this
story but it is a funny story and
interesting a baseball team has
apologized after including congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio Cortes in a sort of
compilation of enemies of freedom
alongside North Korean dictator Kim Jong
hoon it's a unusual and bizarre story
which I encourage you to read although I
didn't have time to get to it on the
Regular Show today and then also from
the demo from the David Pakman show
subreddit and our
from NPR pointing out that the
Democratic presidential field will look
a lot smaller by September and this is
something I'm actually going to dig into
in some significant detail next I'm
going to talk about the new requirements
from the DNC to continue qualifying for
debates and I'll talk about whether
these are too strict not strict enough
oppressive pro-establishment
anti-progressive whatever but I'm glad
that people on the subreddit are
following that story because it is an
important one
join the discussion we have numerous
moderators on the david pakman show
subreddit I like to keep the
conversation polite constructive non
trolling and the moderators are doing a
really great job of managing the
community which now has more than 10,000
of our viewers and listeners regularly
participating go to david pakman.com
slash our EDD IT hit the subscribe
button onto 15-thousand it would be
great to get 15,000 subscribers to the
david pakman show subreddit